Hello,
and welcome to the Active Inference Lab.
This is Active Inference
Gueststream number 3.1.
And we're really excited to be here today
with Sarah Hashkes.
We are going to be talking about,
as the title slide suggests,
Active Inference, VR and psychedelics.
So, Sarah, I'll leave it to you
to just introduce
the topic yourself
and the ideas however you want.
And it sounds like
we're going to be having
a first section of the presentation,
then a question answer
and then a second section
of the presentation.
At that, we're going to have a second
overall discussion.
So with that kind of structure in mind,
just introduce yourself
and please take it away.
Hi, everyone.
So, yeah, we're going to be talking
first about my research
in VR and Active and friends
and then my research in psychedelics
and how it relates to a few issues
about active inference.
And we'll have a short break
in the middle for questions that I have.
My name is Sarah Houseguests.
I have a master's degree
in cognitive neuroscience.
I opened the first VR lab in the motor
control department at Radboud,
where I was researching VR.
Its effect on our brain body connection
within the predictive coding framework.
I am now CEO of Redlich Motion,
where a startup that combines
neuroscience and immersive technology
and we're focusing on
empowering the psychedelic ecosystem
with embodied tech.
So now let's get right to it.
A lot of this is basically all of this
lecture is based on my research
from academia was pretty nice to go back
and read all the things from 2017.
But before I actually get into it,
I like to activate our actors
and friends
and very short interactive experience.
So wherever you are,
especially if you've been sitting a lot,
actually suggest you stand up
and hopefully you can see
my hand on the screen.
And I'm going to ask you
to put your hand in front of my screen
and just follow it for a few minutes.
Do it with your mouse.
Move your mouse.
Yeah. Okay.
Well, okay. We can do that, too.
You can see.
Oh, I see.
You're not seeing my face in this.
Okay. Yeah.
So follow the mouse for a few seconds
and see if you can track this.
So what just happened here?
So, okay, I gave you auditory
instruction
that hit your brain and created a goal.
A top down prediction
that you were supposed
to. Well, you didn't see my hand.
You saw my mouse.
But basically, that prediction was that
the position of your hand to the mouse
should be the same position.
The difference should be zero. Now
your eye.
And we're then giving you bottom up
sensory input that we're telling you.
Oh, there's this difference
between the mouse and the hand.
And due to active inference,
wanting to minimize
this prediction error,
your hand was moved towards the mouse.
So this is a very simple example
of active inference.
And this follow me
instruction and activity
is really quite basic for how we learn
motor skills as children.
And you can see this in the way
kids play games
with if Simon says, you know, patty cake
and the way children's
look to their adult figures to actually
copy them and learn movement patterns
and this Follow Me example
was part of the research I was doing.
So we'll get into that
though.
What exactly was I trying to do?
Well, I was really hoping that
if I could receive visual cues
from inside of a body of a professional
mover, I would be able to activate
this active inference ability of my brain
and actually improve my movements.
I have a background
in martial arts and dance,
but I'm actually from Thailand,
a very, very clumsy human
that took me really, really, I guess
a lot longer to learn motor skills.
And I was looking for a way to hack this
and I kept dreaming,
Oh, if I could just be inside
the body of my martial arts
teacher,
would I be able to punch like him?
Would my body learn to adapt
and move faster and more accurately?
Because I would be receiving this
prediction that I am actually him. So
this is sort of where
I started
exploring how I could research this.
Now, why would I even think it's possible
using VR?
So part of the things about VR
is that it doesn't
just activate your visual sensation
and sensory input.
It's actually a multimodal integration
between your visual perception
and your proprioceptive, auditory
and even haptic.
If you're currently using
like haptic controllers.
In my experiment, I just was like
we were using the SDK, one of Oculus,
no haptic controllers.
I was connecting them to lab equipment
to get positions of the hands,
but we were still connecting visual
and proprioceptive sensations,
meaning basically
when you move your neck around,
the world is still moving
the way you're expecting it to move.
So you're getting the same upper body
and neck
activations of muscles
of where you are in space
along with your visual perception.
And that activates
these higher brain areas
and really gives you
this what we call the sense of immersive,
immersive ness, right? Immersion.
You're in that place.
Your brain believes it's real,
even though you know, parts of
you know that it's not.
Now we are really gives us
the very unique ability
to influence the brain
because we can start
controlling the relationship
between the different sense in
in ways that either fit these previous
top down biases or don't.
So we can this we really modulate
the amount of prediction error
that we're receiving and activating
in the person's brain.
And there's really
a lot of experiments out there
that that have been done.
For instance, with anorexia patients
and people with pain issues
that really prove
that we can give a new sense of self
to a person.
So when I talk about a sense of self,
what am I talking about
from the predictive coding perspective,
the really, really
great paper by apps?
And just curious
that really I go about explaining
this concept of a minimal self
being the top down prediction
that just explains
the sensory correlations
between the different senses.
And a great example
is the rubber hand experiment.
So if you don't know
this hand is
your hand is actually hidden from you.
Like in the photo,
but it's receiving sensory input
at the same frequency that you're seeing
a rubber hand being semi stimulated.
Now researchers are a bit cruel
with this experiment.
They at some point
take a hammer and smash the rubber hand
and you can really see and register
and record the physiological
measurements from the person
and how that person gets dressed.
Now, newer research is actually showing
that this isn't the same for everybody.
There's some people that seem
to be more susceptible
to this versus others that don't.
There's some amount of suggestibility
and I guess maybe
strength of what is your own self versus
how you do all this top down
prediction is in society
might be actually quite different
and we'll talk about that later.
But generally
there is the very strong ability for us
to change our sense of minimal self.
And we do this all the time
when we wear clothing.
Our predictive ability is become able
to just predict the way this sensation,
unless, you know,
you're somewhere on the autistic spectrum
and then every little itch
and things can drive you crazy,
but also using tools,
this ability to really extend
what we call our minimal self.
So I was hoping that
with VR I'd be able to transfer myself
from a clumsy person
into somebody that can do movements
that are much, much more difficult
and a much faster time.
So what did I actually do?
I needed to find the task that was known
to be a hard task that I could measure.
Right. What is the difference here?
So what was a task
that's called by manual interference?
So by manual interference
is basically our inability
to create different movements
with different patterns
and get an actual interference pattern
between them.
A very simple game, which is what I could
add in my experiment,
is try to make circle in one hand
and a square with the other
and just try again.
And what basically happened is that your
you go between
phases of making circular movement
and phases of making square movement. So
I set out to look at this task and see,
can I improve this task and people
with various VR interventions.
So oops, I don't know why
this new finding here, but okay,
so let's look a little bit
at the experimental design
exactly of all the different things
that I was doing.
And I'm not going to go into exactly
all the analysis.
You can read the paper
because I want to talk more about like
the actual discussions and
what are the ideas that come from this
that we can implement in our daily lives.
But there are basically
a few different conditions.
One condition was a follow me condition,
similar to what we did
at the beginning of this lecture,
where you had an avatar
that was able to do these movements
and you were instructed
to follow the avatar.
The other instruction was complete
the movements yourself.
So there's self
expert experiment
and there's a follow experiment.
Now on the follow experiment,
we were actually discover
that we needed to hide
the square and circle because then
the minute people were already predicting
that we're doing a squared circle,
they were not following as much.
So when you were following,
you were doing random follow movements
along with periodic
small parts of circles and squares,
which I then analyzed
specifically those effects.
So that was one,
just like I'm going to say, sort of this
like baseline condition to see
what is the difference between following
someone versus doing these movements
yourself.
And the second line
that you can see on this design
experiment
was a bid of making things
on screen here
with what we can do with VR.
So the second condition,
when you moved your right hand,
you actually saw your left hand move.
Now, there's no way I can recreate this
for you without putting you inside of VR.
It's a very trippy experience.
Everybody, like with what you're like moving your right hand, but your left hand
is moving
and that really, like, messes up
your predictions.
Now, the third experiment
I put you inside of the avatar
that was able to do these movements
and then told you, follow the movements
or just become this avatar and follow
the movements from within this avatar.
So we actually manipulated two things.
One is the high level path. Go right.
Follow versus move yourself.
Now we assume that the self movement has
a very strong high prior of allowing
only one task.
This is something that, you know,
we're sort of
meant to be doing naturalistically
one task at every given time.
We also have this basal ganglia
that's really blocking
more than one activation
of a physiological or a motor activity.
So that was one thing
we manipulated follow versus.
But there's
do yourself and the second manipulate in
was of the visual feedback right.
Do you see your own hands moving
through your weird crossed hands moving
or do you see an avatar's hand moving
from the perspective of your own hands?
Now, there's again
the difference here when I crossed
your hands, we're really giving you
lots of prediction or prediction error
that doesn't fit
the normal, minimal self activation
and predictions
that you have versus
when I'm putting you inside of an avatar
that's moving in the same way
that you are trying to move.
I'm actually not doing something
that's against this minimal self
prediction, and we'll see how
these things give different results.
So let's go with start
with the first thing
that I was most hoping to get.
Oh, I'll just plop myself into an avatar
that can do these movements
and I'll be able to do that.
Well, that didn't work.
In fact, we got the exact opposite.
So when I say
and this increased the interference,
it mean that people were less able
to perform this difficult task.
They were having even more
periods, both hands doing the same thing,
either circle or square,
and not able to differentiate
each of them.
So what actually likely happened here?
Right.
And this is sort of a theory because
I was not looking at neural correlates.
I was just looking at behavioral data.
But there is a general consensus
in literature that the visual modality,
at least for most of us,
is much stronger
than proprioception and data.
So it seems that we were getting this
mismatch between the sensory
input, right, of I'm
seeing my hands doing the thing,
but I'm feeling my hand
in a different place right now.
I was hoping that with
that would cause active interference,
pulling your hand
to where they're supposed to be.
But it feels that the actual actually
the opposite happened.
And because when I asked people,
they were all actually believing
that they were doing the task better.
Some of them actually thought
they were the avatar.
They didn't even realize
that this was a preprogramed avatar.
They thought it was them
and all of them reported it to be easier.
So but when I looked at the data,
all of them
were actually doing much worse.
So it seemed that the visual modality
cause the proprioception modality
to actually lower and become,
you know, less accurate.
And your brain decided
when it has this this a higher prediction
or there's a few tactics it can do.
One is active inference,
the other is modulate
one of the modalities,
and it seems that that's what it did.
This lowered the proprioception, stuck,
stuck
with the sensation from the eyes,
which it could predict.
And that's the way it sort of minimized
the prediction error.
So can talk a bit more in the discussion
about the meaning of this
and how what it means for training.
But this was, again, you know, it was
against what
I was hoping and against my
my initial prediction.
But thinking about this a bit deeper,
it doesn't make sense because accurate
feedback of what you're actually doing
seems to be incredibly,
incredibly important for a learning
any type of skill.
So giving this false feedback
of somebody doing the movements
seems to not be the way to go around
actually teaching movements.
An experiment
I would love to conduct in the future
as having both of these as an overlay,
like have
the avatar
that's able to do the movements,
but they'll give you a physical ability
to actually know where your hands are.
And this is something that if people have
VR, they can actually download my
my VR app that's called meWe, which lets
you play with these things yourself,
but it basically records 3D movements
and then you can move around them
and also get haptic feedback
and see where your hands are inside.
So I played around with that a bit
with like professional jugglers
creating movements and then me stepping
inside and needing to follow their hands,
but also receiving the feedback of where
my hands are through haptic feedback
and visual perception.
But I did not do an academic research
on that yet.
And that I think
could be really interesting
because I think
there might be something there
because obviously the prediction error
was increased,
meaning your brain needs to deal
with this prediction error in some ways.
So there is a potential of still creating
better updates and maybe activating
this active inference ability.
But we need to not only trust
the visual perception
in visual versus proprioception,
the visual just wins
and you don't feel where you are anymore.
At that same level of accuracy.
So that was interesting.
Now let's look at the other
two conditions
of what I found. So
and the other two conditions
I found that when I actually gave people
the totally incorrect things
that were against their minimal self,
I crossed their hands.
They were moving their right hand,
seeing the left hand,
something that they've never,
ever experienced before.
They were able
to follow the avatar better,
but the
self movement movements were worse.
Right?
And that actually does make sense
because again, we're interfering
with that self level prediction
and having to maintain this goal
of doing a self movement
while your whole minimal self
is just like totally wonky
and doesn't know what's going on
and has a much higher prediction error
is causing interference and making you
not able to do this task as well.
But a follow a task where you don't
actually need to go is really different.
You don't actually need to have a goal,
high level, goal
oriented self structure
that's creating these predictions.
You just need to really minimize
this location in space versus
the other person
they were actually doing better.
And we'll talk a little bit about why
why that might have happened.
Yeah.
So just
one more finding before we go into a bit
more of the discussion
is that there was actually
two very different strategies
might have been employed here as we see
between the two different tasks.
Right when you're in the self
task, this fire prediction error
that you need to deal with is that you
can't just make yourself disappear.
You need to keep maintaining the skill.
So maybe your brain created a weaker
prediction, right?
And then it would just like lower
that prediction error
by having a wider sort of,
I guess, and there's a lot of between
like stronger or weaker and wider.
My specific professor was very
the in the prediction
predictive coding game looking at things
from actually not a continuous Gaussian
but more of a discrete level.
And a lot of this is about like details,
the level of detail of your prediction.
So if you have a less detailed
prediction, you're going to decrease
your prediction error rate if you say and
we'll talk a little bit more about that
when we talk about psychedelics
because it's very relevant there.
But if you're just saying,
okay, my hand needs to be around here,
you know, versus your hand needs
to be exactly at a specific point.
That's another way
to decrease prediction error.
So on the self task, that might be
what was happening.
Your brain was just decreasing the detail
of the prediction.
In order to decrease the prediction error, which would result in worse behavior
versus the follow task.
Your brain might have reduced
the prediction
error by actually
reducing that visual perception
and getting on the relative
right between proprioception
to visual, actually
getting more of this proprioception,
creating these closer feedback loops with
where your body is in space
and getting this more independence
between your hands because you don't need
to have this single task anymore.
You're just following.
And an interesting finding.
I don't have the quote of the paper
here, but
there was a paper
that did the exact same task
but with eyes closed and just touch.
So people had their eyes closed
and we're just touching
something that was moving in a
by manual independent manner
and they were all able to do it. It
suddenly from becoming a very difficult
task that came a very easy task.
So this really shows that sometimes
and I think anybody that practices
movement, it's sort of a common trope.
But there's this thing of like thinking
too much.
So goal oriented movement can actually
if we are taking this goal
oriented movement and putting it in a way
that's too detailed,
we're telling our brains, create
these movement path and create
two separate movement paths.
That's a really not naturalistic
state for our brain to be in
versus when we're
just like, okay, we're following things.
That's a very naturalistic,
the low level feedback between our motor
cortex and our proprioception
and our sensation can just work.
So yeah, that
that does all sort of hopefully under.
Understood.
Now another finding
that that happened was that
there was a much higher variance.
Like I was expecting this
to be a very hard task for everyone.
That's what the literature said.
But I found that and again,
this is a small experiment.
I'm about like 13, six students, right?
I'm all healthy subjects,
young, but
two of them were very able
to do the baseline task,
and that was a surprise to some of them.
The task was so difficult
that I could barely use the data
because they were literally
just moving one hand.
The other hand was just freezing in space
and the other hand withdrew.
So they weren't even able to maintain
these two goals and move two hands
in separate ways at all.
So that
really goes to
show just how different our brains are.
One of the interesting things to compare
this experiment
to is binocular rivalry,
which has been written
a lot about
and that predictive coding literature.
So for whoever doesn't know
this binocular rivalry
is when we project
two different images onto each.
I so one eye is seeing one image
you can see in the picture
the right eye is getting a red image
with one
angle of direction and the left eye
is getting a different one.
Now what happens to your brain
is it actually switches your perception.
It switches between seeing
one of the images and the other images
with some short phases,
usually of like mixed perception,
but really just bouncing
mostly between one to the next.
Now here, too, there is a lot of variance
in the population.
And one of the interesting things
is that people on this
autistic spectrum,
which, you know, I have,
and this criticism about the
DSM and how we're classifying
autism and generally
mental health and different types of
brain,
brain abnormalities,
but some people definitely
have much more mixed states
than others, and different
drugs can also affect their ability
to have mixtapes.
And it's sort of interesting
to compare these two tests because
both of them are sort
of creating a bio stable system
coming from an unnatural mystic
task or a naturalistic
input that you're
not usually supposed to be doing.
Because the way our brain
was really meant to be doing
motor actions is around high level goals.
Completing high level goals. Right.
Give me the border.
Turn on the thing.
Grab bang.
There's always a high level goal
that's oriented towards one of our high,
higher level needs or lower level needs,
but like a specific need
that you're trying to complete.
And with this task of telling people,
Oh, move your hand
in this motor pathway and your other hand
in this motor pathway,
it's very naturalistic for our brain,
very similar to giving someone
these two different visuals,
which we never see in real life. So
again, this is really
correlate to this
having a very strong hyper prior
and in a binocular rivalry situation,
your brain has a very strong hyper prior.
No, I can just this doing one thing
this this is how the world works.
There can only be one thing in one place
and then your brain activates
in order to minimize this prediction
error, it goes between, okay,
and I guess I'm seeing this one now.
It keeps getting prediction error.
Oh, I guess I'm seeing the other one.
So it keeps jumping
between these two states
in order to minimize the prediction
error.
Now, the same thing quite likely
is happening with this
by manual interference
with having a very strong hyper prior
of Oh, I'm only supposed to be doing one
task at any given time.
You're just giving me two different
tasks to complete at the same time.
I'm going to be switching between them
now, possibly
when you have this different sense
of minimal stuff, this can actually
create different activation patterns
and let you be more in a mixed state,
more in an independent state,
have basically
weaker hyper priors around
either what you're seeing
or what your task abilities are.
So this might be an interesting way
of generally understanding
a lot of what our hyper priors
are doing to us.
And just the variance in the population
might be around
these hyper priors.
So let's, let's
now let's get into like more of like
what are these possible implications
and how can we use this data to like,
you know,
do cool things with rehabilitation
and even just training and getting
me to be less clumsy. So
one of the things that that
comes up from this is really naturalistic
design of movement goals.
Instead of telling people, move your hand
at this angle, we step over here
and we see this a lot actually in
in traditional martial arts,
they give movement names of activities
like in kung fu, where you have
stroking the horse that the horses mean.
In karate
we have a move that's called braking,
braking the wall or braking the gate.
So having these goals
that are really oriented towards
task completion
verses goals that are to low
level are much more likely
to activate this active
inference and ways that we want them to.
When we put the goals into the low
level patterns,
we're
then creating this sort of a naturalistic
activity and maybe
even like slowing things down
like the fast parts of our brain
that deal with bringing together
these sense modalities
of visual sensation and motor actions.
They need to stay down there.
They need to not be part of this
high level
stuff, you know,
network
a part of our hierarchical network.
And I think that's really interesting
because that really
is like what I was doing.
Every martial arts teacher
my whole life has told me,
Stop thinking,
I don't know what to do about this.
You know, how can you stop thinking?
But part of it is letting these low level
parts of your body
do the movements
while maintaining high level goals
that are not oriented to exactly,
oh, where is my elbow?
Is it here or here?
Where am I holding my fist?
Like all these little details work
much better if you give them high
level metaphors somehow that your brain
that the lower levels can then
take those predictions
and minimize prediction error.
So that's
another interesting part of this,
is that it might actually explain
some of why mirror box therapy works
and why mirror box therapy is now
something that's also being used in VR
and so for whoever doesn't know
where box therapy
is used on amputees
and people that have pain in one
hand, like chronic pain or even stroke,
people
that had suffered through a stroke.
So what you do is you take the body part
that is actually
okay, that doesn't have pain,
that is working.
And you use a mirror to
then get your brain to believe
that your other body part is also moving
and is healthy or even there
if it's an amputee.
And this was actually figured out by,
I think the first person was Ramachandran
working with amputees that were suffering
from just phantom pain
and how do you get rid of pain
from a limb that doesn't exist anymore?
Right.
This was like a top down prediction
from the injury
that was just not getting updated.
And you see this a lot in chronic
pain, really.
You see the neural circuitry
even change as the predictions for pain
just cement themselves
and become biases in your brain.
So by using this type of mirror
box therapy
and helps relieve the pain.
So why or how is this connected
to what we just saw?
Because the visual modality is stronger
than the proprioception modality.
It's not too far fetched to believe
that the visual modality
is also stronger than the nociceptors
the pain receptors that we're getting.
So if we can actually cause your brain
to believe and just by seeing cause
that visual perception of a healthy hand,
it might be enough to mute
the same way your proprioception
was muting to mute your nociceptors
and then reduce the pain.
So that's that's really interesting.
And it's interesting to see the arteries
inserting teasers with stroke victims
to actually help them
rehabilitate their hand.
And that's really interesting
because that's a little bit
not in accordance with what I saw
for my experiment,
but it might be different
because they might not
be getting current data about them.
And I think it might be really dependent
on, you know,
what the stroke
has actually damaged in your brain.
If the stroke part
has damaged your ability
to receive
any type of proprioceptive data,
then maybe getting that
dual perception might help reprogram
that.
That might be less of an interference
going on. I'm not sure.
It's sort of interesting to think about.
So let's see.
What are we left with? Oh, yeah.
So now
there's basically that third condition.
Why I gave this crossed hand condition,
and I think that's really
an underutilized mechanism
generally in any type of rehabilitation
and training, messing your brain up
even more in some ways.
And I think that that's
a very strong intervention
that we could play around with a lot more
because it's, you know, 100%
we're creating more prediction area
that your brain needs to deal with.
Now, how your brain will deal
with that prediction will it actually
remodel with to create active inference
will reduce some other sensation
might really depend on the
tasks on your brain on how we do this but
being able to increase prediction error
in your brain is a very powerful ability.
And I think that's something
that really is worth looking into more
when we're talking
about rehabilitation tools
and we see these types of things
starting to emerge in VR,
more with like total body replacements,
like I was talking about, about like
anorexia patients are putting them
in a whole new avatar
and creating a full body
rubber hand experiment.
So they're getting sensations
on their body at the same time
that they're seeing their avatar
and getting sensations.
And it's been proven
to help them remodel this
top level belief, an accurate belief
that they have about their bodies
being overweight, though they're not.
So that's very interesting.
But I think there's really a lot
that we can do
with increased massively
increasing prediction around the brain.
And you see this
in a lot of crazy experiments, right?
Like the upside down glasses experiment
that people just within a short
time were able to really adapt
and live in a world
where everything is upside down
or with like training people
on bikes that work in
a totally different direction. So
sometimes by making things harder,
we're making things easier
for our brain
or we're forcing it out of this
minimal potential, well,
that it might fall into say, okay,
now there's too much prediction error.
It's time to actually teams because
as we've been talking about like
this minimal
prediction error,
if you're in a stable state
where you've minimized prediction error,
that's not always a healthy thing
for brains.
And side note,
this is also a model of depression,
basically not having enough prediction
or and your brain falling
into a too stable state,
a low entropy state of your brain.
So increasing prediction
error in many ways can be very important
for our physical health or mental health.
And that's something that I personally
try to hack on myself all the time.
I'll do like dark showers
so I can't see anything.
I'll try to use my left hand
to to use toothbrushes
and just like very basic
daily activities that you get
very used to doing this
put another constraint on yourself
and make it like a fun game.
That's also a great way to train
in any type of physical task.
Okay.
So yeah, we talked a lot about the visual
dominating the proprioceptive, but why?
Why is that so?
There's a paper from 2009 not going.
I don't know how to pronounce that,
you know,
but their theory was
that it's around using tools
that in order
for us to be able to use tools,
we need to be able to not trust
the proprioceptive sensation
as much as the visual perception,
because we don't have data
from any proprioceptive data of any tool
that we're using.
So that's a very interesting theory.
But for my paper,
I think there might be something
actually deeper than that going on.
I think and this might be interesting to
figure out a way to test this on animals
that don't really use tools.
But I would expect it to
a positive and this might might be
very different to some animals you know
actually smells their smell world is much
more dominant for their hearing
but I think that for this goal
oriented movement
where we need to coordinate many body
parts, you know, you're driving a car,
you're just getting out of bed and
and getting dressed or walking.
All these things require
lots of body movements, working together.
So in order for that to happen,
we really need to reduce
the proprioceptive sensation
so we can get this high level goal
to dictate
the lower level hierarchies of the brain
to actually pull towards
the active inference.
If we had very strong perceptions
of where we are right now,
we wouldn't be able to move into
the next state of where we want to be.
So we're taking our brain
is taking this high level goal
and breaking it in to movement
predictions.
And for those movement predictions
to be able to move your body
into where we want it to be
using active inference, we need to weaken
where you are currently and have a weaker
now in order to get to the future
of this goal oriented movement.
That's that's sort of how I see it,
at least
a sort of
interesting thing
that I'd like to talk about
is the openness to discussions
and questions at the end is how this
connects to flow state and improv
and dance and play and all these things
that I am totally infatuated with
and want to spend most my time doing.
So flow states for
if people haven't heard
this term before, it's
a term that's been coined
when athletes are really anybody
that's good at a specific
task is at their peak.
It's been sort of
defined as freed from self-consciousness.
Now a way to look at it
through the lens of these experiments
and these hierarchical levels and
predictive coding and active inference is
that it's basically
inhibiting actually these higher level
abstract goals
and letting us get hyper accuracy
within this proprioception modality.
So really what we call
being in the now, right,
getting incredibly fast feedback loops
that aren't about the end goal.
It's not about if you
I think talk to any of these aspects,
it's not about winning,
it's not about getting to the end.
It's just like this pure joy
about being in the moment and
and letting your body be great.
And a lot of this really might have to do
with inhibiting this
higher level of our neural hierarchy
so we can get this hyper
accuracy of proprioception,
so we can create these vast
feedback loops between our body
and the environment
to get to this
like higher level of performance.
And this takes us to more of
like improv, dance and play
that are really non goal oriented.
This is sort of the definition
and how I see, you
know, there's a big difference
between games and play games.
There's always like you're winning,
you're going towards a thing
or you're losing.
But in play there's none of that.
There's just exploration.
The same goes really was improv dance
compared
to, I don't know, ballet
or choreographed dance.
You're just exploring the possibilities
face of what you can do
and that at least for me
and I think, well,
not only for me,
this is quite widespread.
Anybody that is into these things
I think finds them the most joyous.
And, you know, kids
find them the most joyous.
And it's a very, very healthy part for
our brain to not be in a goal oriented
movement pattern
and to just let go and explore
without having
a high level active inference happening.
Active inference is it's still happening,
but it's being sort of driven
more by the bottom up signals and really
the momentum moment possibilities
without having this like,
okay, that's going to do
let's do like a pretty move,
let's do a pirouette, let's do something.
Yeah.
So I don't think
I actually want to show this video right
now, but it's more about focus on VR.
But if you want to look at it,
if the cool video that's called
This is Your Brain on VR that we made
this predicting
the sound and stuff won't work.
But it sums up a bit about the
what we've been talking about,
how different modalities get expressed
are activated in your brain on VR,
Reprograming, your predictions
and how we can play
with these things.
Okay. So yep, that's the thing.
That's what that, that's awesome. Wow.
I wrote down
a ton of stuff.
So how I ask
some questions
and we'll head into another part.
Yeah.
Many places to jump in.
I really just cut onto this weaker
now like a weaker current moment
in order to get further
so that where you connected that
to accessible experiences like the play
in the martial arts, really awesome.
So when you talked about active inference
kicking in,
what is happening there
and what did you mean by active inference
as far as the way that individual person
might relate to it?
And what like domain or give me more.
You talked about how you talked
about predictive coding
and how active inference would kick in
or would go into a different mode
depending on whether.
Yeah, yeah.
Being a, a high level
or a low level or low level.
Yeah. Exactly.
Like we're always going to be.
I mean, there's always prediction error
in our brain rate
depending on what's happening now.
Are we going
to minimize it with as with what?
There's again,
these three different tactics
that your brain can employ or one,
reducing that sensations
to updating your prediction
three, doing an action.
So when you're just in this replay,
there's still a need
to create a prediction of your movement
pattern for it to actually happen.
Right?
But it's happening at a much lower level
of your neural hierarchy.
It's not happening.
But Cath, there's a high level part
that's saying, Oh, I want to look pretty.
I want to get my teacher to like me.
So I'll do something.
It's happening
at the level of the sensation,
at the level of what feels good
from the proprioception, the haptic
that the pure like your body
knows what's
joyous to your body, or these lower level
predictions and biases
that your body has about
what is joyous, healthy for your body.
The knowledge is there.
There are these lower level biases
that we're allowing our system
to collapse into a state that's being led
by these lower level biases.
And this goes, I think, like in both
ways, this can go very much into like
your body knows and has biases around
what's healthy and fun and feels good.
But there's also that's
where trauma is stored, too.
Is that an amazing book?
I think it's called The
Your Your Body Remembers and
both emotional and physical trauma
really are stored in our low level biases
of our prediction
around our movements and our bodies. So
that, too,
can be, you know, a big issue for many,
many people that to deal with this
and and being able to
go from a state
where your brain's triggered.
Right. And the mental health
basis is called like when you're
when you've been triggered
and these bias negative
biases appear
that are predicting options,
how it's going to happen,
even though there's
no objective reason for that
except your history.
Something's triggered that prediction.
So being able to switch into that
place in your brain
that knows what feels good for your body
and what's healthy for
your body is super important,
and we don't really know how to do that
in a very reliable way.
Yet, you know, there's mindfulness
practices,
breathing and stretching and massage.
But I think, like my biggest fear is that
we're with technology, we're actually
being pulled away from our body.
And that's generally what I'm trying to
close that gap.
Wow. So any sense.
Thanks for this answer.
And it's actually related
to this next question.
You talked about how in the avatar
was getting almost like false
perfect feedback.
It didn't improve the actual performance.
So it really highlighted
how the technology can't just
just simply mechanically demonstrate
like a scaffold.
It has to give somehow accurate
feedback, yet
it's often fantastical scenarios
or abstract scenarios.
So I wondered, what were your thoughts
for technology design?
How could technology
be used to actually enable and enable
these kinds of states
that you're getting towards?
Yeah,
without constraining us in that way.
Yeah.
So I think that was a
very big learning for me. Right.
You need to give a person accurate
feedback
of where they are too
and what they are actually doing.
And there
again, there might be an ability to
impose to such predict
things like you might be able
to still be in a first person perspective
with someone doing the movements,
but also either feel with vibrations
like if you train you, that's
what happens.
I just used a haptic feedback to tell you
if you're are in the right place,
you'll get a vibration.
So I'm strengthening your ability
to know where you actually are.
So there's sort of ways
to hack our other seventh
modalities was, you know, music
really is a bit of like gamification
when you're on the path
of of doing the things
that were you're trying to learn actively
this that, you know, like the dopamine,
you know, dopamine at least
within the predictive coding framework,
it's really like a precision signal
for for prediction error.
So like give some more bling bling bling
with a little bit randomness
when you are doing the things that you're
trying to learn correctly.
But you need to get that feedback
of when you're
doing things correctly.
And I think that's what was missing from
so from this experiment was giving
and the faster and tighter
these feedback loops are,
the more your brain will perceive them
and actually activate them.
So there is some really great,
you know, meditation tools
that you'll meditate and afterwards
you'll see your heart rate.
There's some more professional
like biofeedback rhythms that you can see
what's happening there with ITI or
heart rate in real time.
And that's so actually I talked to before
we started like I'm build
I'm starting my first hardware project
to do that
and give real time
biofeedback of heart rate with LEDs
you're going to go it's called
wisdom truffle it wisdom truffle dot com.
You'll see a trippy truffle
and basically that's
the idea of helping
people reach some of these
tighter feedback loops on a lower level
by hacking their their visual modalities
like let's use that.
We figured out, okay,
the visual modality is super strong,
can we connect it to other sensations
that we don't have as much insight to it?
Could I connect the visual modality
to heart rate?
Yeah, pretty easy.
Can I connect the visual modality
to perception? Yeah.
If you go to MU
when you dance and move your actual
your avatar changes color
and the sparkles change color.
So by hacking the visual modality
that really is like our brains
graphic computer
it's like super strong, it's dominant.
Can we use it in different ways
to connect sensations
that we don't have as strong
and are not as dominant in us?
That's that's one of the things.
Awesome.
And that point
you made really about the high level
priors, like both
my eyes are looking at the same thing
and you can kind of play with that
by pushing on one lately.
And, you know,
it just does distort the image
and it sort of it just demonstrates
it's one of those examples
like the high acuity
in the periphery or color vision,
the periphery or the blind spot.
One of the examples that help bridge
between, for example,
input output, information processing,
understandings of cognitive sciences
versus
this really extended and predictive way
that you're talking about thing.
So it's really awesome
and thanks for making
it really accessible
with this presentation.
So you want to go to the second part
and that one has questions life.
Otherwise I'll just keep on. Very cool.
Thanks, John. Thank you.
So okay, we're good at.
Context, context, reset.
It's like context.
It's there's a context to it,
but we're still staying
within the predictive coding
framework and active inference. But
yeah, I'm going to just give, you know,
I really like this idea
of giving visual metaphor based on
all the things that I talked about.
I think that's a great way to learn and
and have
this intuitive understanding
both of math.
I don't know if you follow the three blue
one brown videos, but they're just
phenomenal and mathematical understanding
because it's all visual coded math.
But I'm going to give a visual metaphor.
You can
either look at the images
or even close your eyes
and just imagine that when your brain
is creating reality, it's very similar
to playing in the sand
with some buckets and making sandcastles.
And the sand is just this
constant incoming bottom up signal.
There's so much of it, constant sand
that's flooding
into your room, into your space,
and you have these buckets
and you're trying to take all the sand
and put them into the bucket
constantly to create this
reality, really.
And this is
pretty much what your brain is doing, but
at least in the predictive
coding framework,
with the buckets being these top down
priors and the sand being the bottom up
and incoming signals.
So there's a constant buckets trying
to predict and put the incoming signals
into a specific bucket
that then turns off the sand, basically.
Now, let's talk a bit
about the classical psychedelics.
Psychedelics.
So they're starting to expand to be,
you know,
like basically everything that
classical psychedelics or whatever
activate the five to a receptor
agonist just means activating.
So what really happens
when we take a classical psychedelic
is that these your brain's buckets
are getting broken down
into smaller
and differently shaped buckets.
So your priors are getting broken down.
They're getting diffused into
sort of weaker but more accurate
or more detailed
buckets that let your brain create
an actual different reality for itself.
Now, where is it coming from?
When we look at the actual micro
circuit of the brain
and this is of the cortical,
you have seven layers of your cortex
and how the neurons
are actually laid out there.
This is a very amazing paper by best that
we can see exactly the feedback loops
that are correlated to predictive coding.
Where are the
where's the data going, upwards of which
we see in these forward connections
in purple, it's coming in from layer
four, it's going up to layer two
and then looping to layer five.
And then where are the backwards
connections that are coming
from these higher level brain areas
that are correlated to our predictions?
And we see that in grit
coming from layer five,
going down to Layer four,
doing these these feedback loops.
So when we look at where
the five edge due to a receptor is,
we see that they're situated
very specifically on these layer five
on the backwards connections basically.
So we're seeing that they're activating,
hyper activating
and making the sensitivity
of these neurons
much more sensitive.
So that's that's why
the theory is that it's
causing these predictions
to fire at a much lower threshold,
if before and let's imagine
a whole neuronal population,
you'd need to get, you know,
X amount of neurons resonating together
to create a prediction.
Now you need much less of them.
Just a few neurons are like throwing out
their own prediction
and a few other
neurons are throwing out their prediction
and you're
getting many more competing predictions.
So the very simple metaphor,
if you're walking down
a forest and usual state,
you might have a probability of 0.4%.
Oh, I'm going to see some animals
and a 0.6% prediction
of I'm going to see some plants.
But after you've taken psychedelics
and these predictions have decomposed,
you're you might get a much more detailed
prediction possibility space.
You know,
maybe you're going to see a dog, a cat,
hey, maybe you're going to see an elf.
That's, you know, a low probability,
but it's suddenly there.
So things that were below
the threshold of probability
are now becoming a higher threshold
and part of your predictive
probability space.
Now, what really happens here up
and what's really sort of important
is how this correlates
with the rest of your bottom
up sensations.
If you are in a very getting
very clean bottom up signal,
which almost never happens,
but let's imagine
a very clear auditory signal,
at least for a moment, or very clear
visual perception that you're getting.
Suddenly you can have much
higher accurate predictions.
And this is, you know,
people on psychedelics,
including myself, will report
this quite often like, oh, wow,
I can see footprints in the forest
the way I've never seen them before.
Or this perception of hearing music
and like the audio is just so crisp
and so detailed
in ways that I don't perceive them
when I'm not on psychedelics.
But if you are in
bottom up environment
where you're getting noisy signals,
it's dark
things that are constantly changing.
There's various sounds
that only the possibilities
and the predictions
that you might be getting
are might not be as correlated
to, you know, quote unquote,
objective reality.
Suddenly,
your predictions can become much stronger
and just or much less
accurate.
But still,
a type of overfitting might happen.
That's, I think, a good word to use here
where, you know, oh, I'm in this forest.
It's dark and gloomy.
There's something moving.
Oh, it's an elf, right?
Because that was part of the probability
space of your prediction.
And with the noisy, bottom
up incoming sensation,
that was enough
to reduce prediction error.
But what's important to note,
and you can see sort of in this
very simple image,
that the decompose predictions
are all less strong.
So they're not going to turn off
as much prediction error.
So your your brain is going to constantly
be while you're on psychedelics
and the state that has higher
prediction error, which as we saw
before and we've been talking about
when you have a higher prediction error,
your brain has a few different tactics
that it can use to deal with it.
One, modulating the senses
to updating predictions.
Three Active inference, right?
So this is why psychedelics offer a very,
very unique opportunity
of updating your model, because there's
a much higher level of prediction error.
And then under some situations,
your brain might decide
to actually update the model.
And if people are suffering from trauma
and depression,
we're seeing absolutely amazing results
in research around using psychedelics
to update people biases
around these things.
And again,
very much depending on the setting, don't
expect to take psychedelics
and go to a place
where you don't feel safe in
and you don't have a support structure.
And to get these benefits
in order to update your model,
you need to be getting bottom up
sensory inputs that are very strong
and accurate around
what's happening to you right now.
But if you do that
and you are able to feel safe
in your body like we talked before,
be in place situations or improv or flow
that might allow your brain
to really, really heal deep
traumas, to really reprogram deep biases
from childhood when your brain was more
had this extra neuroplasticity.
So now let's get to active inference.
So the interesting part about these 5c2
receptors
is that we don't have so many of them
in our motor cortex.
There's a lot left of them.
So we can actually see that active
inference
modulates psychedelic experiences
and makes them weaker.
And we see this both in the instructions
that people are given
when they're doing psychedelic therapy
right now.
Maps, for instance, or other
universities and hospitals
that are researching this,
they really tell people,
lie down, don't move.
And when I talked to therapists
about this, they can really say,
we know when something's
bubbling up with a person.
We see that in their body
when they're coming too much,
they start really moving.
And we try to encourage them to
actually they still because then they
when we start moving, we're actually
weakening the prediction error rate.
Our brain is creating a prediction
that's still pretty stable because we
don't have as many
receptors that
have been activated or activated
because we took psychedelics
and the motor cortex.
So our motor predictions are able
to modulate this psychedelic experience.
And you know that the benefit of
this is that, oh wow, if you're are doing
and you're feeling really overwhelmed,
move, do a bunch of jumping jacks,
push ups, move around space.
That's going to really help
the prediction error in your brain
and help
you be more back.
I guess the reality you're used to.
So yeah, this was a short
connection between psychedelics
and active inference
that I just wanted to
bring to the space to oh.
Thank you. Now
there is so much even that.
That I could you know.
You can answer that and I'm.
Sure you've
just.
Perfect and I'll just then
I'll just really crop it.
I guess I'll drop it
while I ask this first question, which is
you point out
that a lot of the even the clinical work
on psychedelics is done in a way
where they actually prevent movement
and also like education, saying like.
I say, prevent that, don't encourage it.
Yeah.
Yeah. Okay, yeah.
Totally
like putting people on the street.
But it's, it's, it's on a continuum
with an authority as a restraint.
And so just yeah, yeah.
What is maybe the role of the body
in remote work or in
now that we're also in again
not physically
restrained to our chairs yet,
but it feels like that some days.
It's a disaster. It's
yeah I think we're
and I'm a total motor chauvinist
when it comes to our brain.
I don't know if you've heard that term
before, but no, explain that.
Yeah.
So basically we have a brain
in cognitive functions because we move,
you know, when you look at the animal
at the at the designation between trees
to algae to creatures and the crazy ocean
to animals that move, when do you start
getting brains is when they move.
And there's a great example
of some really insane sea
creature
that moves around and has a brain.
Then it finds a place to plop itself down
and digest its own brain.
So wants.
Yeah, it doesn't need it.
Our our brain is needed to create
predictions with the environment.
Right.
This is the whole predictive coding.
And Andy Clarke has a beautiful book
and papers about
about the feedback loops that we create
within with the environment.
And if our environment
is relatively highly predictable
because we're staying in the same place,
then guess what?
We don't we we don't need this.
And we and us as humans and Andy
Clarke also goes into that quite a lot.
We sort of because we won out minimize
prediction error that's that's part of
this whole free energy thing in our brain
but we've done it a bit too well.
You know, we've created these
large scale active
inference cells with our environment
shaping our supermarkets, looking the
same, the roads to our house.
And I think that's
a really a big cause of generally
the mental health crisis
that we're seeing
and especially when it comes to
then not even moving your body,
being in the same state,
another physiological state
that's too low entropy.
And that's really, really
I think I'm going to even go to the
of sentencing
like my main goal in my in my work
is that one metric improve
the amount of states
your body is for humans.
If I do that then
for, you know, modern
citizens that have a total lack of this,
I am absolutely certain
that we're going to see improvement
on many metrics
that we're lacking.
So when it comes
right, try as much as I can to like
not fall into this like
I've been working remotely for
even before this crazy
COVID thing happened. But,
you know,
do calls while you're walking outside
or stretching outside,
anything that doesn't require you
to be in front of it, to the screen.
Yeah. Spring or is yeah.
Create like we do have the ability
to gamify and bring toys
into our environment like you have rings
outside and punching bags and
any anything that will create
constraints around your movements.
You'll move desk, change your table,
don't work from the same space
if you possibly can.
Just keep bringing in that prediction or
both into your body and
and I think that's a very
like incorrect way
that ergonomics is looked at.
You know, ergonomics is all about
like let's find the perfect for this.
Know for you to be in for many hours.
That doesn't exist.
We're not supposed to be
in a perfect position.
It's going like this.
Well, it's it's really
it's like a modern mental ergonomics.
And it's the ergo the work,
the dynamics of a dynamical system.
That's us.
And so the ergonomics is now the back
angle for the chair, but then there's
actually a ratio of the chair
and the exercise ball or whatever.
That's not my.
Specialty,
but it's all about taking those ratios
because whatever is
there is no such thing as as the
the perfect sitting state
or not moving state for.
Your body, you know, lying down
too much gives us pressure on problems
and people in hospital need to be turned
around to not get things.
We are a dynamic physiological system
and I think there's a very big gap
between
people that are studying these systems
a lot of the times.
And like most people and computer science
people that are just really not
spending enough time
connecting to their own bodies.
So I think, like,
I highly encourage everyone to like
just find the time to figure out
what you are as a full human being
is like blood and
blood pressure bones, tendons
and be
in that
space and let that those prediction
take precedence
at least a little bit of your day.
You know, one thing you mentioned
is this like top down,
almost standardization
and synchronization
and stabilization
of the lower level states.
And then the two affordances we have kind
of like our physical movement
and our communication, and we've seen how
those are subject to top down
as well as bottom up constraints.
But that is kind of what's being remapped
is the constraints on our movement
variously in our communications
networks, variously.
And so to have a multi-scale framework
like active inference
or we can talk about the remote team
having input and output
and then the body, we can be like, Here's
an algorithm that's awesome
for this sector, for this team,
but I want to be not reinforcement
learning driven or not reward driven.
I want to have a framework
that allows me to express
these kinds of playful states
or even have a rationale
to construct these states and design for.
Yeah, so I think there's that was a lot,
a lot of good point you brought up.
So maybe first
the communication thing, right,
we're doing this, this 2D,
sometimes only voice, sometimes
2D screens that none of this
is naturalistic for our brains.
Right? We're 3D creatures.
We pick up social cues from being able
to gaze into each other's eyes, predict
where you're looking at
and take, and it gets worse.
Number of people you bring in just
I like group zooms for me art for sure
there's so much awkward silence,
so much inefficiency.
Who's next?
What is the level of even
when we're in a normal social group?
You know, I
usually put little numbers around people
how much I think they understood me.
Okay.
This person understood 70%, 30%, zero.
And I do the same for myself.
And I try to be very honest
with people I like.
I understand around 30% of what
you just said,
and that's how we are.
Like, we have different data
internally and managing to like minimize
the differences in these
data structures is a very difficult task,
even when you're not working in remote
and remote work is definitely made that
a lot more difficult.
I tried to use things like VR
and found it sometimes okay,
but also it's an I'm a superb your,
you know, enthusiastic person
and still spending more than 15 minutes
in there.
And a period of time is just too much.
It's heavy, it's clunky,
it's a close point of view.
So that's that's a difficult thing.
But we do try what we do tried to do
a lot of the time is create
mockups directly in VR
and share this the mockups in VR.
So we understand what
we're trying to build together
from this 3D perspective.
Generally, I'm me, you.
We have like an air app or I'm
trying to create interactive holograms.
So more on the social connection
instead of just
getting you on like a 2D screen
or the Facebook and Instagram.
But getting something
that moves in my face
and actually interacts with me
like you can blow kisses.
I don't know if you ever seen the Roger
Rabbit movie,
but I realize I think I got it.
Like I started it when I was a kid.
And then I built this thing.
I saw the movie again
and I was like, Oh, well,
I just thought the Roger Rabbit thing.
Notices through the screen or. Something.
You blow kisses
and it goes into your 3D space
in air space,
so you can actually move around
your space and cast the person's kisses.
So I'm really excited
about the possibility of creating
what's called joint action
and cognitive neuroscience remotely.
And joint action is a physiological thing
more than anything
like if they even shake your hand
or just passing you,
that pen is when I start predicting you
and starting to predict you
is starting to build empathy with you.
So these empathy things really
are naturalistically based
on very low level physiological data
and without this because we're currently
constantly on zoom
and you know, I,
I click here to send you a button
to send you a chat or I raise my hand
by clicking a thing and.
You see a thing over there,
it's much, much weaker
and not really
creating of these joint actions.
So I think there's a
to explore with technology
was just joint actions and
team building activities that are in VR
even if for a short period of time
and just simple things
like let's go lock together
or things that you would do
in physical space
if you could be together
to just understand a bit more on this low
level prediction of who a person is,
how they move.
Now, we are very
so you can like mess things up.
I don't know if you've ever been
in VR chat, but you can interact with
someone as like,
Oh, I know a three meter giant
with fire wings and I'm a tiny pixie
and you're just interacting this way.
So I think that's really interesting
and I actually can be
a very interesting way versus
biasing things like,
Oh, what happens if we conduct interviews
that are not like,
we know, we know there's a huge bias
in the whole hiring system
and building teams to begin with
that is not solve.
There's like, okay, you do
and you know, you don't even.
Right. Sometimes h.r.
Doesn't look at the names
and there's all these things
to try to hide who the person.
But the moment there's interviews,
you know who the person is
and these racial biases come
in, these gender biases come in.
So there's a lot
of really interesting ways that we be
biasing ourselves by
just, again, this excessive
prediction error and and the ability
to really detach ourselves
from the normal perception that we have.
But that's really interesting
about the physical components of remote,
whether it's a physical object
that's going to be moving
and I don't know, like a, you know,
little jellyfish that does a movement
or just synchronizing.
And it made me wonder
if there was like an exercise,
like could people just say,
okay, beginning of this video?
Yeah,
maybe we all just switch over a context
like let's do, you know, three claps
and take a deep breath and just do it
and think of a, you know, purple cow and.
Then just coordinate that way
and then prepare or here's our narrative,
here's what we're here to do.
Because that kind of stuff, the mission
which comes back to your earlier idea
about like giving the information
in the way that's naturalistic
and what is the natural unit.
It's kind of a the goal, the end.
And so having the group assemble
with the synchronization and and also
a remembrance of the end is like really
an interesting implication,
I think, of active inference,
but not some of these other subcomponent
theories per.
SE Yeah, and so that's our so what
I am trying to do with this hardware is
let people synchronize their heartbeats.
Let me you're over there. I'm over here.
Let Me send you
my heart beat a beautiful glowing pulses
and you can send me your heartbeat
and get this biophysical data
that honestly if we were even in the same
room together, I wouldn't necessarily
get unless
I was like touching you. Right?
So I think we are
and this is the exciting part
of like immersive
and embodied technology.
Like we are getting to the stage
where we can start
moving
beyond 2D video into biophysical data
that lets us get a deeper understanding
and deeper connection and deeper
synchronization with each other.
Well,
I'm happy to talk for a little bit longer
if you want, but I guess my closing
thought or at least correction,
because maybe we'll see
or hear from you again would be like,
what are the next steps
for applied active inference?
Or for an individual who's curious
about these kinds of topics?
Is there like a website
or is there a research direction?
Where is active inference coming into
play in the next months, two years?
Yeah.
So honestly,
before I heard about your podcast,
I've never heard about any stats
like focus within the predictive
coding framework.
I would be very excited about
connecting and this is something I've,
I've been trying to do
is bring movers into the it seems that
there's two different worlds.
There is rumors that heat technology
because they feel it's
taking them away from their bodies
and there's there's
technology and science
and there's a very unfortunately,
very small overlap between them.
And that's what you know,
I was very lucky I found a co-founder
who's in both of these worlds.
But if there was a way to bridge this gap
and like you're saying, these, you know,
movement exercises, it's a thing
that we do constantly and improv classes,
building physiological synchronization.
And the things you'll see there
sometimes are just like, this is one
organism,
you know, like people moving together,
not pre-decided.
And there's a beautiful research paper,
I think.
Noy It's from,
from Israel.
There is not a faculty
I can link, link to it afterwards.
But what they did is
they tried to figure out what's going on
in the brains of
improvisers
and have a beautiful
like mathematical paper
about the double feedback loop
that's created.
So it's not and they tested
two conditions leader versus follower.
That was more what I was testing versus
there is no leader and follower.
You're doing things together
and they found a much higher degree
of synchronization and a very
they built a very cool paradigm
of just like moving your hand
on one up and down.
That's it.
Very easy to measure,
but it was there, the data was there.
They managed to find a much higher degree
of synchronization
when there was no
leader and follower between
improvisers
that were either musical improvisers
or dancers and trained their brain
to tune in to the other person
because when you're doing this
and this is a very
you know, when you're talking about teams
and synchronizing and and play,
I think we really need a shift
in the hierarchical structure of teams
like I don't see
and this is something that I'm
really exploring a CEO of a startup.
How do I get these ideas
that I want out there?
But how do I bring in people's ideas
so they feel that they're part of this?
And how do we then get a cohesive
product at the end of it?
Not none of
these are like easy questions,
but having this ability to
double feedback.
So it's not just a top down manager
that's saying, Oh, this and this
and this.
You guys understand this
and this and this, this is my vision.
Don't Expect people
to be excited about your vision.
Hey, that's not how these things work.
If you want them to be excited
and attuned,
you need as a manager
in this hierarchical structure,
be attuned to their visions,
what they're seeing, their perspective.
Why did they join this project
and try to get that coordinated
into a global vision that is,
you know, doesn't break apart
because there's too many voices.
So none this is easy.
But I think that a lot of the times, yes,
going to the low level physiology
first and building this low level
physical trust with each other
and understanding with each other
is really unique.
Like me and my co-founder,
we dance together.
We climb on trees together.
Before he moved to Hawaii.
Now we try to hang out in VR
and do things together, but
it's really not the same.
So figuring out
how to do these joint physical actions
together, I think will really
get us into the future
somehow or a future I want to be part of.
Yeah, nice or unlikely future.
One that I expected. When I. Saw it.
Yeah.
But on that tech and movers
and sort of the transdisciplinary nature
and the potentially
productive conversation,
we kind of
think about these guestrooms
like it's too directional
because maybe for those with a physics
background or a philosophy background,
you've inspired them to think
about how they're
doing their physical activities
or wanting to go deeper
into a knowledge or movement tradition
they were already a part of.
And then people
who that's their daily life.
And then maybe this is the first time
they're hearing about active inference.
So we can always do like event
series or discussions or working groups
or events like that
or projects like that
to help make that two lane freeway
accessible for everybody and respect
both directions of the interchange.
And it's a really important part,
like you said, with the moving away
from the hierarchy of disciplines,
you know, it's physics,
the top dog discipline.
Physics is awesome, but it's actually a.
Really I survived project of the earth
and physics that was dramatic.
Yeah.
It's great.
And then
different
people will be drawn to different parts
and that will be sort of
like the colony phenotype.
And when we
when we constrain with a lower level,
looks like we increasingly infringe
on what the higher level can be as well.
So it's about that balance.
And so that's a common theme
with these active inference discussions
of, well, yeah,
this is awesome,
I really appreciate this conversation.
And it was a, I'm sure
something that a lot of us will be
listen to and think about.
So we hope to maybe interact with you
or other communities in the future.
But this is great fun.
So thanks a lot so much.
Peace!